اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض
نبداها بالعناوين
استمرار الهدوء في السودان والبرهان يؤكد
ان الجيش السوداني مع اي حل ينهي تمرد
الدعم
خادم الحرمين الشريفين يامر باستضافه الف
حاج وحاجه من فلسطين لاداء الحج هذا العام
جدل مستمر حول توطين تطبيقات التوصيل في
السعوديه وتحذيرات من فجوه في اعداد
العاملين
في الرابعه ايضا
وزاره التعليم السعوديه تعلن جاهزيه 200
صاله رياضيه في مدارس البنات بمختلف
المناطق
والامطار تخلف مشاهد ساحره وخلابه في
اوديه الباحه جنوب غربي السعوديه
مساء الخير نبدا من السودان حيث ناقش رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
مع الاتحاد الافريقي ناقش الجهود المبذوله
في منبر جده لحل الازمه في السودان وقال
البرهان ان سبب فشل الهدن عدم وجود اليات
ملزمه لمتابعه خروج الدعم السريع واضاف
المتمردون لم يلتزموا باخلاء منازل
المواطنين والمستشفيات ومراكز الخدمات
والمرافق العامه واكد ان الجيش السوداني
مع اي حل ينهي الحرب
هدوء وتوقف للقصف والاشتباكات في السودان
بعد مرور ساعات على الهدنه التي دخلت حيست
تنفيذ لمده 24 ساعه ويعيش سكان العاصمه
الخرطوم حاله من الترقب خاصه بعد خرق
الاتفاقات السابقه حيث اكدوا ان الوضع
الميداني خلال ساعات الصباح كان هادئا من
جانبه قال مكتب الشؤون الافريقيه في وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه قال انه واشنطن تواصل
الضغط على القوات المسلحه وقوات الدعم
السريع وذلك بهدف وقف الاعمال العدائيه
وتسهيل وصول المساعدات الانسانيه واستعاده
الخدمات الاساسيه واوضح المكتب انهم
يراقبون الاطراف المتحاربه في السودان
باستخدام الاقمار الصناعيه وادوات اخرى
يذكر ان هذه الهدنه الاخيره تهدف بشكل
اساسي الى تامين وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
الى السكان البالغ عددهم نحو 45 مليون
نسمه حيث يقدر ان نصفهم يحت اجون الى
المساعده
معنى من اندرمان الصحفي في مكتب العربيه
في السودان شهدي النادر اهلا بك معنا
الشهد الى نشره الرابعه اذا هدوء ووقف
لاطلاق النار ووقف للاشتباكات مما يعني
التزام بالهدنا حتى الان انقل لنا ممارسهم
في هذه الساعات الاخيره
نعم فاطمه يستمر الهدوء الذي بدات به هذه
الهدنه منذ دخولها حيز التنفيذ في الساعه
السادسه من الصباح هذا اليوم نحن الان على
مشارف الساعه التاسعه من عمر هذه الهدنه
ما يزال الهدوء هو سيد الموقف في الصباح
كان هدوءا حذرا ولكن الان باتت مساحات
الاطمئنان تتمدد حاله السكون تتمدد لدى
الناس هنا في ظل غياب وانحسار المواجهات
بشكل كامل في عموم ولايه الخرطوم بمدنها
الثلاثه لم نرصد حتى هذه اللحظه اي ذوي
اشتباكات او ذوي قذائف مدفعيه او تحليق
لحركه الطيران سواء كان الطيران المقاتل
او الطيران الاستطلاع فقط الادخنه التي
اتتصاعد هي تلك التي اندلعت بعد الحريق في
مستودعات الغاز والمشتقات البتروليه في
جنوبي الخرطوم هذا الحريق وهو ما يزال
متواصل لليوم الرابع على التوالي وما تزال
ادخنته تت لكن بخلاف ذلك سماء الخرطوم
هادئه تماما لم نرصد اي اخر حتى هذه
اللحظه الناس هنا نزلنا نزلنا اليهم قبل
قليل تحدثنا معهم ياملون ان يتم تمديد هذه
الهدنه باعتبار ان فتره 24 ساعه اخير
كافيه للقيام بكثير مما ينتظرهم بعضهم
يرغب في السفر بعضهم ويزال اعالق يريد ان
يطمئن لي امانه الطريق من اي خطر من اي
اشتباكات ربما تندلع كثير من الناس اترقى
فيه السفر ترقب فيها التنقل ما بين المدن
العاصمه بعد انقطعت العمليات العسكريه
التي لا تدور بجوار كثير جدا من الجسور
العاصمه وشوارع والطرق المؤديه الى هذه
الجسور قطعت عليهم بعضهم الديه اموال في
منطقه اخرى لديه اوراق او مستندات مهمه
وخلافه الجميع يامل ان يتم تمديد هذه
الهدنه وان تستمر بهذه بهذه الكيفيه التي
بدات بها بطبيعه الحال ولكن شاهدين مدى
رصت من ناحيه يعني فتح المحال التجاريه
المخابز حركه المواطنين يعني ذكرت بان
هناك حاله من الاطمئنان بدات تسود
يعني هل لك ان تحرك الكاميرا قليلا ربما
لنرى الصوره من خلفك
هذه هذه هي صوره اليوم هناك ضباب وهناك
السماء هي صافيه الا باستثناء هذه الادخنه
من جنوبي مدينه الخرطوم هي ما تزال عالقه
في سماء المدينه ومرئيه لغالبيه سكان
العاصمه مدنها الثلاثه بالعوده الى سؤالك
حول المحاله التجاريه
والمخابز المحاله التجاريه فتحت ابوابها
الاسواق الطرفيه كذلك فتحت ابوابها هناك
ازدياد في الحركه ملحوظ حركه المواصلات
العامه اليوم عدد عدد الحافلات اكبر بكثير
من ما كان عليه خلال الايام الماضيه هناك
حركه بعض المواطنين من كانوا عالقين او
خلافه استطاعوا ان يصلوا الى بعض
المستشفيات الطرفيه هذا في جانب طالبي
العلاج على العموم هذه الهدنه تمضي بشكل
جيد من خلال ما رصدناه لم نشاهد اي خرق لا
توجد اي اشتباكات حتى هذه حتى هذه اللحظه
جمعيه الهلال الاحمر السوداني فاطمه قالت
بانها عكفت على توزيع بعض المواد الغذائيه
بالتعاون مع برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في
بعض المناطق التي تشهد هدوء نسبي بدات
قالت بانها قبل ايام توزيع في غربي وجنوبي
مدينه درمان كذلك في الريف الشمالي في
مدينه ام درمان وبعض المناطق فيها الخرطوم
تامل ان تتماسك هذه الهدنه بشكل اكبر تامل
تحديد مسارات تعين على ان تصل الى
المستحقين والمستفيدين من هذه المواد
الايقاديه في عده
العاصمه وما رصدتم حول ذلك يعني هل خرجت
القوات المسلحه من داخل المستشفيات
المدارس المنازل هل توقفت عمليات النهب
نعم عمليات النهب هي في الاسواق الكبرى في
المخازن هي ما تزال مستمره فيما يلي مساله
خروج القوات وتحديد القوات الدعم السريعه
التي تتمركز في بعض المستشفيات في محيط
اخرى حتى هذه اللحظه لا جديد في هذا الامر
وزاره الصحه بحسب اخر بيانات لم يصدر عنها
حتى هذه اللحظه ما يفيد بان هناك جديد في
الامر ما يعني ان حوالي ثلاثه واربعين ما
بين مستشفى ومؤسسه طبيه حيويه هي ما تزال
خارج الخدمه كل مستشفيات وسط الخرطوم هي
ما تزال خارج الخدمه محطات المياه كذلك ما
تزال خمسه اربعه وخمسه منها هي خارجا هي
خارج الخدمه بحسب اداره هيئه مياه ولايه
الولاده الخرطوم فان الامر فان فتره الارض
وعشرين ساعه هي ذات نفسها الغير كافيه حتى
يتم صيانه الاحطاء التي تتواجد بهذه بهذه
المحطات كما ان التواجد التواجد العسكري
وتحديد القوات الدعم السريع في بعض
المحطات وبجوار وبعضها سيعيق وسيرفع من
الدرجات خطر الخطر على العمال ممن لن
يرتدو ان يذهبوا فيه ظل تواجد خطر يتربص
بهم جرائم اندلاع اشتباك مفاجئ او خلافه
لذلك كما قلت ان اناناس باتت هنا تتوقع ان
يتم تمديد هذه الهدنه طالما انها مرت بهذا
الشكل من الالتزام
شكرا جزيلا لك من اندرمان الصحفي في مكتب
العربيه في السودان شهدي نادر
وفي دارفور اعلنت الهيئه النقابيه لاطباء
ولايه غرب دارفور عن رصدها لعدد من
الانتهاكات الجسيمه لحقوق الانسان في
مدينه الجنينه واضافت ان المدنيين يتعرضون
للقتل والتشريد الى جانب عمليات النهب
والحرمان من الوصول الى مصادر المياه
ومنعهم من مغادره المدينه مشيره الى ان ما
جرى في رواندا في العام 1994 يعاد الان في
الجنينه
قبل ذلك طلبه الحكومه السودانيه من
الاتحاد الافريقي عدم التعامل مع المبعوث
الامي فولكربرتز ومن جانبه يتمسك الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو تيريش تمسك
بمفرده الى الخرطوم رغم رفض الحكومه
السودانيه وقال المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده ستيفاندو جافيك ان اعتبار
الحكومه السودانيه مفيد المنظمه الدوليه
شخصا غير مرغوب فيه يتنافى مع مبادئ الامم
المتحده ولا يمكن تطبيقه لافتا الى ان صفه
الالماني
لم تتبدل
خلافات السودان مع البعثه الامميه لدعم
المرحله الانتقاليه
مصدر حكومي قال بيرس انحاز الى اطراف
سياسيه محدده في العمليه السياسيه واستبعد
اخرين
وقال البرهان بيرس اخفى معلومات حول
الاوضاع في الخرطوم قبل المواجهات واضاف
البرهان حميدتي اطلق العمليه العسكريه
بسبب اكاذيب
تظاهرات ضد بيرتش من قبل انصار الجيش
واطراف سياسيه ضد ما وصفوها بتدخلات
اجنبيه
بيرس تلقى تهديدات بالقتل قبل اندلاع
المواجهات في السودان في مايو عام 2023
اتهم البرهان بيرس بانه متحيز وطالب
باستبداله
في التاسع من يونيو عام 2023
السودان اخطر الامم المتحده بان فولكر
بيرت شخص غير مرغوب فيه
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد امر خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز باستضافه الف
حاج وحاجه من فلسطين لاداء فريضه الحج
لهذا العام وذلك ضمن برنامج ضيوف خادم
الحرمين الشريفين بدوره قال وزير الشؤون
الاسلاميه في السعوديه عبد اللطيف ال
الشيخ قال ان استمرار استضافه برنامج ضيوف
خادم الحرمين لحجاج فلسطين بشكل سنوي ياتي
تاكيدا على نتائجه الايجابيه مشيرا الى ان
البرنامج يشمل جميع مناحي تاديه الحج بما
في ذلك زياره المسجد النبوي والاماكن
التاريخيه وعقد اللقاءات الثقافيه
والعلميه
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في اخبار الحج حيث وصل الى مكه
والمدينه حتى الان اكثر من 800 الف حاج بن
حجاج الخارج وحددت وزاره الحج السعوديه
يوم الرابع من ذي الحجه اخر موعد لاستكمال
لوصول الحجاج من خارج المملكه هذا ومن
المقرر ان تطبق هذا العام تقنيات اليه
لرصد حركه الحجاج من داخل 160 الف مخيم
بشكل رقمي ومباشر ضمن حلول رقميه تقدمها
السعوديه لحجاج بيت الله
معنى من مشعر من مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز
اهلا بك معنا نواف في نشره الرابعه انقل
لنا الصوره لديك
نعم فاطمه البنيه التحتيه الرقميه
المتقدمه في مكه المكرمه والمشاعر المقدسه
ساهمت بشكل كبير جدا بالتسهيل على شركات
الحج لتقديم لخدمات الكترونيه متطوره
للحجاج بدءا من التسجيل وحتى وصول الحجاج
الى المخيمات في مشعر منى وحتى الانتهاء
من مناسك الحج
والمغادره هنا نتواجد في احدى المخيمات
النموذجيه او كما تعرف بالمخيمات المتطوره
في مشعر مينا وهي تعمل بالخدمات
الالكترونيه التي ترصد حركه الحجاج داخل
المخيم وايضا ترصد طلباتهم والشكاوى
الخاصه بهم ومعالجتها من خلال الانظمه
الالكترونيه التي تقدمها شركات السعوديه
مع الان مدير هذه الشركه احدى شركات الحج
عبد القادر الجبرتي اهلا وسهلا سيد عبد
القادر في
هو اصلا الكتروني نعطي للاسره بشكل عام
رقم حجز زمره
نسمره حتى نستطيع السيطره على تسكينهم في
للرجال مع الرجال والنساء مع النساء في
نظام الكتروني محكم في هذا الموضوع
ماذا عن الخدمات المقدمه مثل الخدمات
الطبيه وايضا الاسعافيه في المخيمات لديكم
ممتاز احنا نوفر طبيب وطبيبه وممرض وممرضه
ونعتني بموضوع الاسعافات الاوليه والادويه
اللي هي المطلوبه دائما
[موسيقى]
وجميع
الخدمه المسانده الطبيه موجوده نعم ايضا
نحن الان نتواجد في احدى غرف المبيت
للحجاج نلاحظ التغير ترتيب معين كيف هذا
الامر ايضا يدعم راحه الحجاج خلال التواجد
في المخيمات في مشعر منها طيب هذه الغرفه
احنا
جهزناها
للتصوير عموما
هذه بتلم
خدمه الرجال وخدمه النساء في المبيت عندنا
في نظام اسمه نظام الاداره بالالوان اللون
الالوان الرجال ياخذ لونين صالح لون وصاله
لون نفس الشيء بالنسبه للنساء حتى تساعد
وتساهم في
انه يصل الحاج بسهوله لخيمته الحاجه يقضي
تسعه وتسعين ساعه منها في المواصلات ومنها
في الاكل والشرب ومنها في المبيت واحيانا
يتوه فاحنا نساعده في هذا الموضوع في نفس
الوقت كمان نعطي رقم للصاله ونعطي رقم
للسرير ونعطي رقم للشارع ونعطي رقم الله
يكرمكم للدورات المياه ونعطي رقم حتى
للمغاسل الحاج اذا وجد اي ملاحظه في اي
مكان يستطيع بالرقم عبر التطبيق يقول لنا
احنا والله انا احتاج كذا نوفر له في على
سريره
هدايا تساعد في الاقامه
فمن ضمن هذه الهدايا هي قصاصه تضافير
المصحف المياه الزمزم المظله
مناديل اللي هي المنشفه الكاب
شنطه الحصى السداده العين
سجاده فاخره طاوله طعام اللي هي طاوله
الكمبيوتر كل هذه الخدمات تقدم من اجل
راحه الحجاج في نفس الوقت احنا عندنا نظام
نسميه في عندنا مشرف علاقه لكل حاجه
يتواصل معه ويعرض عليه مشاكل ويخدمه في اي
وقت هذا هذا النظام اصلا مرتبط بنظام
الكتروني
رقمي يحدد شكوى الحاج ومتى تم حلها وكيف
تم حلها وهل انتهت
كله في بنظام رقمي الكتروني كل الشكر لك
سيد عبد القادر اذا فاطمه كما تشاهدون هنا
في احدى غرف مبيت الحجاج في مخيمات مشعر
من كل الخدمات هذه تقدم بدعم حكومي واسع
من مختلف القطاعات بالاضافه الى ان
الخدمات الرقميه تدعم من قبل وزاره
الاتصالات وايضا الجهات
اخرى مثل هيئه الاتصالات وتقنيه المعلومات
هنا هذا الدعم يتم بابراج الاتصالات وايضا
التوفير شبكه الواي فاي بنسبه تتجاوز
الاربعين بالمئه خلال العام الماضي وسيعلن
عن التفاصيل القادمه فيما يتعلق بالبناء
التحتيه الرقميه في مكه المكرمه والمشاعر
المقدسه شكرا جزيلا لك من مشعر من المراسل
العربيه نواف عزيز والشكر موصول لضيفك
الكريم
الى شمال السعوديه وتحديدا منفذ جديد او
جديده عرعر الذي يعد شاهدا على قصه عبير
الرويلي متطوعه سعوديه رفقه اثنين من
ابنائها لخدمه الحجاج والمعتمرين التفاصيل
مع الزميل جزاع النصي
عبير الرويلي سيده سعوديه من مدينه عرعر
بمنطقه الحدود الشماليه السعوديه
دابت على مدى ثلاث سنوات في خدمه الحجاج
القادمين برا من العراق عبر منفذ جديده
عرعر برفقه اثنين من ابنائها
دخلت مجال التطوع بيحب والشغف والحمد لله
صار لي ثلاث سنوات اخدم الضيوف الرحمن
منفذ جديده عرعر سوى في موسم الحج او كذلك
في موسم العمره وخاصه في شهر رمضان والحمد
لله احس بسعاده كبيره وانا اخدم ضيوف
الرحمن لدرجه اني عكست حبه تطوع لاولادي
ولمن هم حولي محمد ابن الثامنه عشره عاما
واخاه وليد يشاركان والدتهما مساعده
الحجاج حيث اخذ منها حب المساعده والتطوع
في عمل الخير شرف لي اخدم من ضيوف الرحمن
ومثل وطني في مجال التطوع بافضل صوره انا
سعيد اليوم في خدمه الحجاج في منفذ الجليد
عرعر اقدم لهم المساعده والمشروبات
الساخنه والبارده
وان شاء الله يصلون الى المشاعر المقدسه
بسلام الامني حابب اشكر اثنين انا امي
وابوي الله يحفظهم لي هم اللي يحفزون على
التطوع هذا وخدمه ضيوف الرحمن
[موسيقى]
عشرات المتطوعين والمتطوعات يقومون على
خدمه الحجاج بشكل يومي طوال فتره التفويج
عبر هذا المنفذ من منفذ جديده عرعر على
الحدود السعوديه العراقيه
جزاعا معصي العربيه
في الرابعه ايضا
جدل مستمر حول توطين تطبيقات التوصيل في
السعوديه وتحذيرات من فجوه في اعداد
العاملين
استمرار الهدوء في السودان والبرهان يؤكد
ان الجيش السوداني مع اي حل ينهي تمرد
الدعم
خادم الحرمين الشريفين يامر باستضافه الف
حاج وحاجه من فلسطين لاداء الحج هذا العام
جدل مستمر حول توطين تطبيقات التوصيل في
السعوديه وتحذيرات من فجوه في اعداد
العاملين
ووزاره التعليم السعوديات تعلن جاهزيه 200
صاله رياضيه في مدارس البنات بمختلف
المناطق
والامطار تخلف مشاهد ساحره وخلابه في
اوديه الباحه جنوب غربي السعوديه
حياكم الله من جديد في السعوديه اثر خبر
حول مجلس حول ان مجلس الشورى سيصوت
الاثنين المقبل على توصيات تقرير هيئه
النقل بعد مطالبه احد الاعضاء لتطبيق نظام
التوطين لمندوبي تطبيقات التوصيل والنقل
الكثير من الجدل حول جدوى تطبيقه تابع
المزيد حوله في التقرير التالي
توطين مندوبي تطبيقات التوصيل والنقل
بالسعوديه بين مد وجزر واقع حبيس بين
انظمه تحفيزيه من جهه ومطالبات بفرض قانون
لتطبيقه من جهه اخرى اخر المحاولات توجه
مجلس الشورى للتصويت في جلسته المقبله في
توصيات تقرير حياه النقل لتطبيق نظام
التوطين بشكل عاجل بحسب صحيفه الرياض التي
قالت ان توصيه التقرير جاءت بعد مطالبه
عضو مجلس الشورى عبد الله النجار
وبالتنسيق مع وزاره الموارد البشريه
والتنميه الاجتماعيه بتطبيق التوطين الذي
اكد ان التوسع في استخدام التطبيقات
الالكترونيه في السعوديه ادى الى دخول
الكثير من غير المواطنين في خدمه التوصيل
دون ضوابط بالرغم من اعلان وزير النقل
سابقا البدء في سعوده القطاع اعلان اللاق
الكثير من ردود الفعل غير المؤيده والتي
اعتبرت ان فرض القرار سيقلل من جوده
الخدمه في ظل الطلب المتزايد والمتسارع
نتابع بعضا منها
[موسيقى]
مطالبات تاتي وسط تضخم كبير لارقام
الطلبات عبر تطبيقات التوصيل حيث بلغت
وفقا لاحصائيات لهيئه الاتصالات وتقنيه
المعلومات اكثر من 28 مليون طلب فقط خلال
الربع الاول من العام 2021
لتفتح ابواب الشكوك حول ما اذا كانت توطين
سيساهم في خلق وظائف جديده امام السعوديين
دون الاخلال بمستوى الجوده ام سيكون
بمثابه سكين في عنق التوسع الذي توصلت
اليه هذه البرامج
ينضم الينا من الرياضه المستثمر في
الشركات الناشئه مشهوره بيان اهلا بك معنا
سيد مشهور بدايه يعني برايك لماذا هذا
الرفض الكبير لهذا المقترح بتوطين قطاع
التوصيل
لسبب بسيط جدا لان الان الطلب على التوصيل
متزايد الان تطبيقات توصيل تتفاوت اعداد
الطلبات اليوميه فيها حسب تطبيق التوصيل
طبعا ممكن 100000 طلب في اليوم الى 300
الف او اكثر طلب طبعا تتفاوت حسب تطبيق
التوصيل الطلب ضخم جدا بالمقابل للعرض من
ناحيه سائقين بالكاد يغطي هذا الطلب فيتم
حصر
السائقين على السائقين السعوديين فقط
فبيكون في خلل كبير بين العرض والطلب وهذا
بلا شك سيؤثر على الاسعار وسياثر قبل ما
يؤثر حتى على التطبيقات التوصيل سياثر على
المطاعم والمحلات والمتاجر الشركه مع هذه
التطبيقات بحيث تنخفض عدد الطلبات لديها
بشكل كبير فلا اعتقد ان القرار مدروس بشكل
جيد وانت تم سيكون اثر وسلبي بشكل كبير
على هذا القطاع كما اكثر بشكل سلبي على
قطاع او تطبيقات توصيل
التطبيقات مثل كريم واوبر المختص في
المشاوير طيب السيد مشهور يعني برايك
لماذا يمكن ان يكون هناك تفاوت وفرق
كبير بين الطلب ويعني الطلب كما حضرتك
تفضلت اذا هل هناك عدم رغبه من الجانب
السعودي او الشباب السعودي للدخول في هذا
القطاع
اعتقد ان الوظيفه
كسائق توصيل ضربات وظيفه غير مغريه
للسعودي اللي عده اسباب اولها نوع الوظيفه
يختلف تماما حتى عن توصيل او عن تطبيقات
المشاوير من ناحيه انه يتطلب انتظار طويل
عند المطاعم او عند المحلات لتوصيل
الطلبات يتطلب حتى التعامل مع روائح الاكل
ونقل
المنتجات بمختلف اشكالها وروائحها
وانواعها ايضا يتطلب كفاءه عاليه في
التوصيل بحيث ان الموظف الواحد يجب ان
نتمكن من التوصيل على عدد كبير من الطلبات
في اليوم الواحد ليحصل على دخل مجزي
اجمالا هي وظيفه لا تعتمد لا تتطلب اي
مهارات وانما تتطلب قد تعتمد بشكل كبير
نوعيه الوظيفه هذه على الاعمال التي
ربما يعني بالنسبه لها الدخل الضعيف لهذه
الوظائف نسبيا
لا يسبب مشكله بالنسبه لهم وما عندهم نضيف
الى ذلك سيد مشهور ربما ايضا يعني الطموح
المهني لدى الشباب السعودي ربما لا يتناسب
ايضا مع هذه الوظيفه يعني لا يستطيعون ان
يتقدموا على السلم الوظيفي ربما فيها اي
حتى مستقبل واضح الى الشاب اذا بدا اليوم
كسائق او كمندوب توصيل وين ممكن يتوجه بعد
كذا اعتقد الافضل التركيز على سواء على
الممكن الوظائف الاشرافيه المتعلقه في هذه
القطاع ممكن
تمكين رواد الاعمال الذي يعملون مع
تطبيقات توصيل الاعمال على قوانين وانظمه
جديده تنظم عمل بين التطبيقات التوصيل
والتجار بدلا من محاوله توطين القطاع
والضاربه طيب برايك هل عدد العاملين الان
في قطاع التوصيل هو كافي ليتناسب مع العرض
والطلب
الان حتى مع كون اغ العاملين في قطاع
التوصيل غير سعوديين الا انه بالكاد يكفي
لتلبيه الطلب وحتى العامل الواحد اليوم في
تطبيق التوصيل غالبا يعمل لدى اكثر من
تطبيق ومع ذلك التطبيقات تجد صعوبه في
تلبيه الطلبات المتزايده على التطبيقات
بمجرد الزام هذه التطبيقات على سعوده جميع
مناديب التوصيل فبلا شك تتواجد صعوبه
كبيره في تربيه الطلبات المتزايده وايضا
سيعكس هذا سلبا سواء عدد الطلبات التي تصل
للتجار او عدد الطلبات او عفوا على سعر
التوصيل الذي يضطر الى دفع المستهلك
النهايه طيب ما الحلول اللي ممكن يستفيد
منها قطاع التوصيل يعني خصوصا انه في
مطالبات القطاع في الحين ارى ايضا معارضه
جدا بسبب التجارب السابقه اللي ربما بقت
بالفشل عندما يعني تم توطينها برايك يعني
التوطين هل يناسب جميع القطاعات من ضمنها
قطاع التوصيل
هذه قطاعات قطاع التوصيل لا اعتقد من
مناسب توطينه في النهايه نحتاج الى وظائف
تبني مهارات وامكانات لدى شباب البلد
تمكنهم من القيام بوظائف اكبر وتساهم في
اقتصاد البلد بشكل اكبر في المستقبل بدلا
من حصرهم على وظائف قد لا تفيد سواء
تفيدهم حاليا وتفيد مستقبله ومستقبل البلد
في شكل كبير هناك مشاكل اكبر في قطاع
التوصيل الطلبات قد تتعلق في المشاكل
الموجوده حاليا او التحديات الموجوده بين
التجار وبين التطبيقات قد تتعلق في
الانظمه والقوانين هناك مكنه اخرى من
امكان التفات لها وتطويرها بدلا من التفات
لموضوع التطوير التوطين الذي اعتقد انه لن
يثمر بنا
ابدا توجه له طيب بشكل عام وما ان يعني
اقدموا على توطين هذا القطاع هل ممكن انه
يؤثر يعني بالتاكيد راح ياثر على القطاع
نفسه ولكن ما نظرنا الى الصوره الاكبر
يعني هل يمكن ان يؤثر بشكل عام على قطاع
النقل على قطاع الاقتصادي في السعوديه
ربما بما انه جانب كبير يعني عدد كبير
ونسبه كبيره من المواطنين السعوديين
والمقيمين يستخدمون هذه التطبيقات
يعني اقتصاديا او اقتصادي
بشكل تعتمد بنسبه قد تصل الى 50% واكثر
على الطلبات الوارده لها تكون من تطبيقات
التوصيل ولن تتمكنوا من تعويض هذه الطلبات
وتعويض الايرادات التي تخسرها نتيجه هذا
القرار لن تتمكن تعويضها من قنوات اخرى
فسيكون ضرره الاقتصادي كبير من وجهه نظري
قد يؤدي الى اغلاق الكثير من المتاجر بسبب
انعدام تلك القناه الفعاله التي تولد لهم
الكثير من الطلبات وبالتالي انعدام
الايرادات الوارده لهم من تلك القنوات
فتوجه نحن نحو التوطين اعتقد انه سيكون له
ضر سلبي فقط ولن يكون له اي فوائد ايجابيه
للبلد شكرا جزيلا لك من الرياض المستثمر
في الشركات الناشئه مشهوره بيان
اوضحت وزاره الدفاع السعوديه ان قواتها
الجويه ونظيرتها الامريكيه نفذتا تمرينا
جويا شاركت فيه منظومه مقاتلات اف 15 اس
اي التابعه للقوات الجويه والقادفه
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
وجرا خلال التمرين استخدام الذخيره الحيه
لتدمير اهداف تشبيهيه في ميدان الرمايه
انشات وزاره التعليم السعوديه اكثر من 200
صاله رياضيه ملحقه للطالبات في المدارس
الحكوميه وذلك ضمن مبادره تستهدف تعزيز
المشاركه الرياضيه في المدارس وتستهدف
وزاره التعليم ايضا ضمن مبادرتها انشاء
740 صاله رياضيه تتمحور تفاصيلها حول نشر
اهميه ممارسه الرياضه لدى الطالبات في سن
مبكره وتشكيل اسلوب حياتها حياتهن بشكل
صحي اضافه الى تعزيز ربط التعليم في جميع
المراحل بخطط التنميه
مناظر ساحره خلفتها الامطار في اوديه
الواحه جنوب غربي السعوديه الزميل عماد
الزهراني وثق لنا شيئا من طبيعه اوديه
الباحه نتابع
الى العراق والتي اعلنت فيها وزاره الصحه
انتهاء اكبر عمليه صحيه مدعومه من
السعوديه وامريكا ومنظمات دوليه بينها
اليونسيف والصحه العالميه تم خلالها تلقيح
اكثر من نصف مليون طفل من الفئات الاشد
حاجه الى اللقاحات ضد الامراض وابرزها
الحصبه
الحكومه العراقيه تعلن انتهاء اكبر عمليه
صحيه من نوعها لتلقيح اكثر من نصف مليون
طفل ممن يحتاجون بشده لتلك اللقاحات
لانقاذ حياتهم من الخطر وزاره الصحه
العراقيه وبدعم من السعوديه وامريكا
ومنظمتي اليونيسف والصحه العالميه تمكنت
من تقديم اكثر من مليون و300 الف جرعه
لقاح الى نحو
50018 الف طفل بينهم ما يزيد على 330 الف
طفل تم تطعيمهم ضد مرض الحصبه الاكثر عدوى
كما جرى تطعيم نحو 50 الف طفل ممن لم يتم
تحصينهم او فاتتهم اللقاحات وعملت الفرق
الطبيه ايضا على توعيه اكثر من مليون شخص
من الاهالي حول اهميه اللقاحات وتحصين
الاطفال حمله اللقاحات لاقت ترحيبا كبيرا
من الاهل لحمايه اطفالهم فيما وصفتها
منظمات دوليه بانها مهمه للغايه
وتعهدت بمواصله تامينات
اللقاحات هي الاستراتيجيه الاكثر امانا
لحمايه الاطفال من الامراض وتلتزم
اليونيسف بضمان وصول اللقاحات الى كل طفل
في العراق الصحه العراقيه اعتبرت حمله
اللقاحات مرحله هامه لبلوغ التغطيه الصحيه
الشامله في البلاد لقد حققت هذه الحمله
نجاحا كبيرا في ضمان عدم اهمال اي طفل في
العراق وتقول منظمه اليونيسف والصحه
العالميه ان فرقهما تعمل بشكل مكثف لانقاذ
الاطفال حول العالم من الامراض والاوبئه
وتمكينهم من النمو بصحه جيده من خلال
استخدام السياسات والبرامج المبنيه على
اسس علميه وطبيه
عقار لكنبي الجديد على موافقه مشروطه من
اداره الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه لعلاج
الزهايمر بناء على النتائج الاوليه التي
تشير الى انه يمكن ان يبطئ من تقدم المرض
لعده اشهر
العقار الجديد صنع للمرضى الذين يعانون من
ضعف ادراكي خفيف وليس الخرف الشديد
الموافقه المبدئيه على العقار جاءت بناء
على المعايير المخبريه او البيولوجيه
عندما اثبتت مساهمته في ازاله الترسبات
الدماغ التي هي سمه مميزه لمرض الزهايمر
اللجنه استخدمت بيانات اكثر حداثه من
دراسه اجريت على 1800 مريض واظهر فيها
الاشخاص الذين تناولوا الدواء معدلا
انخفاض طفيف في تراجع مقاييس الذاكره
والحكم والاختبارات المعرفيه الاخرى
اعلنت مقاطعه كيبيك الكنديه انها ستبدا
جهودا للسيطره على الحرائق الضخمه التي
تشهدها كندا حاليا وبحسب بيانات المركز
الكندي فان عدد الحرائق بلغ اكثر من 2300
حريق خلال العام الجاري منها 427 حريقا
نشطا
و232 خارج نطاق السيطره هذا وعبرت السلطات
الاتحاديه عن قلقها من اثار الحرائق على
البنيه التحتيه والعواقب المتفاقمه للتغير
المناخي
هذا الطريق الذي ياخذنا الى احدى الغابات
التي اشتعلت فيها السنه اللهب خارج
العاصمه اوتاوا التي لا يزال هوائها ملوث
بسبب دخان الحرائق من المواد الخطره اللي
موجوده
بالحرائق الغابات هو غاز اول اكسيد
الكربون وهو غاز سريع الانتشار جدا
وعديم الرائحه ولذلك يعني عندما يستنشقون
الناس
فيحصل اغماء بالبدايه واذا كانت كميه
كبيره تحصل وفاه التاثير لم يختصر على
الجانب الصحي فقط بل اثر اقتصاديا ايضا
فمثلا ارتفعت اسعار الوقود في المناطق
القريبه من الحرائق وصلنا الى منطقه
سنتياليكا التي تبعد ما يقارب 160 كلم عن
العاصمه اوتاوا في مقاطعه انتريو وصلنا
هذه النقطه ولم يسمح لنا بالعبور وذلك
بسبب الحرائق التي تتهم الغابات في هذه
المنطقه والتي من اكبر الحرائق فيها في
هذه المنطقه ايضا انقطعت الاتصالات
وانقطعت اشاره الانترنت المنطقه شبه خاليه
من السكان بسبب عمليات الاجلاء منازل
فارغه وطرق بدت خاليه تم اجلاء السكان
منها ومن لا يزالون يعيشون ولو بعيدا عن
الحرائق سيطر الخوف عليهم من وصولها اليهم
نحن خائفون لا نعلم متى تاتي الحرائق
الحكومه تحاول مكافحه الحرائق لكن هناك
جفاف وارتفاع بدرجات الحراره الجفاف بدا
واضحا في هذه المناطق المحيطه بالغابات
المشتعله التي تشهد اكثر من 50 حريقا 34
منها خارج السيطره لوثت المياه والطبيعه
رفع السعد العربيه اوتاوا
اليكم مشاهدينا صور من استمرار ثوران
بركان كيلوا ثاني اكبر بركان في هاواي
الثوران بدا الاربعاء الماضي بعد انقطاع
عندما ثلاثه اشهر
وهناك براكين عده تثور من حول العالم من
ضمنها هاواي كما نشاهد على الصور امامنا
على الشاشه وكذلك الفلبين تشهد ايضا ثوران
واندلاع ثوران كبير في بعض من البراكين في
تلك المنطقه بالتالي هناك مخاوف من خطر
ثوران بركاني بالاضافه الى ايطاليا التي
حذرت دراسه اوروبيه من ان خطر ثوران
بركاني في منطقه كامبو
قرب مدينه نابولي الايطاليه واصل الى
مستوى غير مسبوق واضافت الدراسه ان هذا
النشاط البركاني بات يهدد نصف مليون شخص
في ايطاليا كما يعرض مئات الالاف من
السكان لطوفان من الحمم البرك انيه
والرماد والصخور
[موسيقى]
ختام رابعه نذكر بالعناوين
استمرار الهدوء في السودان والبرهان يؤكد
ان الجيش السوداني مع اي حل ينهي تمرد
الدعم
خادم الحرمين الشريفين يامر باستضافه الف
حاج وحاجه من فلسطين لاداء الحج هذا العام
جدل مستمر حول توطين تطبيقات التوصيل في
السعوديه وتحذيرات من فجوه في اعداد
العاملين
وزاره التعليم السعوديه تعلن جاهزيه 200
صاله رياضيه في مدارس البنات بمختلف
المناطق
والامطار تخلف مشاهد ساحره وخلابه في
اوديه الباحه جنوب غرب السعوديه
ختام الرابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات